you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of the electronic
triple 2016 welcome to the coop stage
I'm Tanya Dwyer we're here talking about
videogames with the folks from critical
role of Matthew Mercer good to see you
again serving to be here there's a great
pleasure you were gonna rear 5:35 air
five Travis wedding oh that's good
how you doing very well great this is in
your hood right y'all are just like
living around LA it's just like down the
road so yeah actually no I'm in Hinault
booth spend most of my time to be fair I
think it took us about as long to get to
the convention center today is it to fly
to you if you got an exodus this morning
you literally ran into every speed bump
you possibly could yeah I just had my
razor scooter and was just shooting down
from the valley that didn't happen but
that needs to happen yeah well you're
all here now yes indeed part of the
massive crew you guys roll deep critical
role bring with you every time I talk to
you guys it feels like you've reached
another milestone I mean for me now the
latest one is this ridiculous intro
video you have happened since we've seen
you like yes I think was right after you
came down to GameSpot yeah yeah San
Francisco and it great it's just nuts
right it's just nuts it's a power
fantasy you guys have of just like being
able to create this ridiculous show for
the folks who don't maybe know what you
do what is a critical role critical role
is a bunch of nerdy ass voice actors
playing Dungeons and Dragons we we do a
twitch stream every Thursday for the
most part where I Dungeon Master a game
of Dungeons and Dragons and bunch of the
folks that you just saw up here and
we'll see you later all have characters
and we were running the game for three
years it's been on streaming for one
year the same game the same game so I
that that's that's pretty much the gist
of it we're just a bunch of vo guys
rolling dice and playing make-believe
and to be fair a lot of us had never
played before I think in the first two
years of right way we play like once
every two to three
months we get together have a couple
drinks make fun of ourselves we'd really
like long excursion into the night and
have mimosas go to ten and have more
mimosas right you know it'll be good
game good sloppier and sloppy like
stretching your range as voice actors
that's kind of like the more a drink you
try something new yeah they're part of
yeah we're just using it as like a
release right you know it is kind of
cathartic I mean if you're wanting to
kill something you can do that if you
want to like cry a lot you can do that
there's not really anything you can't
mean you you were the one that actually
said like you can do whatever you want
to do I'll never forget it he was like
so it was like seeing into the cosmos
you know like he saw the future and he
was like I can do anything and I was
like yes you can you can try anything
good you can try
separation there you could certainly try
yes
yeah that's your job yes exactly and
that's all your job was also started
teaching a lot of them about TV right
because this all sort of started like at
your house right this was yeah yeah I
started at our apartment and you know
some Lima Brian was one of our players
he'd been playing when he was younger
but hadn't played in a long time and
talented playing for a while and Russia
had a few experiences but everyone else
it was completely new to them right oh
it was you know I didn't freak him out
at first and they came over I had like
my cloak and hood on and had candles out
Satan do not speak master says you may
look it's seance to the immediate right
in their eyes as they enter but I
brought the jobs that did you it's in
the air did you feed the conference and
we all disrobe but no after freaking
them out just watching them kind of get
it and it is just it's adults playing
you get to provides and it's communal
storytelling and and you're all telling
the story together and making a lot of
things up on the spot and seeing where
it goes and it's it's one of the best in
my opinion one of the best experiences
you can have with your friends I mean it
period it's a sort of like a it's a very
like naked sort of calming
thing because you're basically like
acting and being that like extrovert is
often like the people who dd-do D&D Lee
sort of what I think about stereotypes I
think about like the sort of introverted
people but it's it's such an extrovert
sort of like there are also different
ways to play it too and a lot of people
I can honestly say a lot of the reason
why I'm more socially comfortable now
than I was know as younger it's because
I played the indie yeah you know it was
those experiences that got me more
comfortable stepping out of my comfort
zone into a character that was more
confident than I was and for a lot of
people it's a very therapeutic and a
very very great way to find parts of
themselves they didn't know how to
really exercise yeah yeah we've talked
to several elementary school teachers
just in the time that we've started the
show that have begun using Dungeons and
Dragons as a teaching tool for some of
their kids that really have issues with
social anxiety to teach them how to be
able to interact more because if you
think about it it's basically just a
life simulator right yeah yeah that's
all it is so let's let's teach kids how
to socially interact in situations where
it's okay if they fail yeah and they're
not going to be embarrassed in front of
a bunch of their peers yeah you're in a
comfortable situation and they can shed
their sort of the baggage right that
they bring with them everywhere which
conversely leads to why some of the
people that you game with will be some
of the closest friends you ever have in
your life hasn't changed much like when
I think of back in high school like the
thing that like got me out of my shell
was I got involved in like the stage
production and I didn't want to do and I
was at home and I was like I don't and I
my mom was like you won't you'll never
regret trying you'll regret if you don't
try and then I did it they did a bunch
of shows and it just like it helped sort
of like shed that there's a sort of a
duality between not and the type of work
you do as well right yeah
you're basically entering into a room
with presumably a lot of decline people
you've never worked with and have to
make weird noises in front of them yeah
alone in a booth surrounded by foam oh
they're made me different careers right
actually that follow that path but uh
figure Berg but but but Farrar I sent
involves a microphone
and in some padded rooms and people that
go all right make stuff up go yeah
and so yeah I for a part of the reason I
even got in this industry is because I
grew up playing these games and it was
kind of a practice you know element to
give the voices in my head some sort of
focus but I think it lent to you guys so
I never played before
once it clicked me like oh it's just
playing like we normally do but you're
in control as opposed to Locke to his
script it became a really really fun
experience and it's great team-building
exercise it's not one person like really
jumping in like the first game everybody
kind of was looking around the room like
how serious are we really gonna do it
and Laura who plays the most RPGs in our
house was the first one to jump in it
like one of a sudden break out the
accent and be very seductive to new
places and Liam then caught fire and it
just went around the room and I was like
oh god my RP is terrible out I'm gonna
bring a big dumb stupid broom and that's
how it's been for the past three years
Laura it's sick to it like a fish to
water
I know ways she was there and know it on
it is an imaginary bear alright in the
game name drink it and every time it
almost dies I am preparing for the worst
triage of my life because if that bear
dies it's gonna be a week of Hell at my
house maybe candles there might be a
service I'm not sure she may lock
yourself in a room I don't know what
will happen we do have a pact that if
any one of our characters dies we will
go out for drinks yeah Oh God you know
have it like a little weight away drinks
no matter how late it is and I'm pretty
sure trinket is in that category if
trinket goes down don't say that you'll
add they have a reason to take trinket
down is it still I mean like you do
anything for long enough and it starts
to feel like work does it still feel
like that fun get-together for all you
guys like even though you're like doing
it like every week and it's like you now
have this like massive anticipation
following it it's we we made we've made
a promise to ourselves when we started
this if it ever began to not be fun
anymore that we'd stop doing it
then something that that's always a
distant worry but not yet I don't think
not at all and and part of us trying to
keep to the core of what the game is you
know whenever anything starts getting
any sort of attention on the internet
you know a lot of companies come out of
the woodwork and they're like yeah how
can we take this and bottle it and
retool it and stretch it and so we're
being very guarded we're being very
careful that the game and the show stays
what the core that made it you know what
it is today which was just us having fun
and so we're being very careful about
that and we're making sure that we're
not adjusting the format in any way
other than just us with some cameras
playing Dungeons and Dragons anything
beyond that for the show I think would
be a death sentence yeah we're beholdin
to nothing we have no structure he's the
only one that has any idea of like what
the plan is based on what we decide to
do like he'll come to a game and he'll
walk in with these giant boards that are
covered by a blanket or a towel that are
like these arenas that got like a battle
map but he'll come in with like three or
four of them right what are those four
knee goes I got to be prepared man and
some nights he'll leave without we
haven't seen any of them he's like you
didn't you didn't go or I thought you
might go buckles him in that goes them
into the car that's how important they
are very hard and it slides off and the
tiles go over the back seat which has
happened so if a cop option is like can
you open your trunk he's gonna see like
weapons that are like made of platinum
just like the foam that out so that it's
like you know an assassin's trunk no
like we're gonna say well the Rockets
all good okay I'll be a much safer way
of transport years of exactly reader on
the trunk yep the whole thing in the
matrix
I need battle tiles
walls corners yes now that would read oh
that's great you've almost got like you
know because producers are like you know
people involved the higher-ups they like
to like get their fingers involved but
you like have like mystery baked in you
don't even know they might turn left at
the willow tree but that that's to me is
what's so exciting about it that's why
it doesn't get old for us none of us
know what's going to happen no one knows
what the reactions gonna be
I don't know until the moment it does
you know I have my I preset ideas and my
character personalities for the NPC's
and stuff but I don't know what the hell
they're gonna do every session so it's
never it never gets stale because I
never know what's going to happen and
that's really exciting to me not to
mention the community that's risen up
about it like the fantastic community of
critters team human who have gone off to
create their own campaign yeah and let
us know stories and videos and and
inform us of their stuff their own
campaigns they're putting up on Twitch
now it's really cool to kind of watch it
become more than just the show it's
become a cultural you know well
tiny cultural phenomenon for all these
people that have done then taken it and
ran with it it's great the amount of
people that come out of the woodwork and
when we had a chance to play with Vin
Diesel at the beginning of the year
Patrick Rothfuss on who's an incredible
fantasy author good emails and in-person
people are like hey hey the credit the
critical role D&D game are you are you
taking guests and you're like have you
ever played before they're usually no
but I want to be like a thief I want to
be an archer really thought about it and
then you leave the party and go like
what is my life right now
I'm sure if this is like good weird like
secret Club find be like hey bud hey so
uh you know I think I think I could roll
like a character with you guys like does
it make sense to me it's crazy just
telling the first ones free right
happened to marry one of our guys
brothers but they never played before
just like I'd love to try it now she
bought all the books the day after she's
I said she's starting her own game with
a bunch of other voice actors in private
as well I've never played so I guess
just spreading it's spreading yeah
what's that like hearing about people
who have like you know especially like
folks you've never met before like just
random people who like watch on the
twitch streams
every single week like hearing about
them picking it up oh it's amazing I
mean each person that I hear that's like
hey you I played my first game because
you guys I that's a victory yeah like
the more people who play Dungeons &
Dragons I have this like insane theory
that I think that if everyone played
Dungeons & Dragons or a tabletop RPG at
least once that the world would be a
better place like a way happier more
understanding place so each person that
I think can experience how incredible is
it's that's therapy almost is it's used
as a form of therapy for a lot of people
I see people are like have like that
social issues there been a lot of people
who have a lot of like autistic children
and kids are time adjusting socially at
a young age it's been a really great
tool to bring together and forge friend
groups and to essentially get people
interested in the idea of interacting
other people it's been that's so many
great facets of it it's it's it's been
really cool to be just even a small part
of its recent resurgence somehow which
is still a wild thing to consider yes do
you think you guys have like sort of hit
a wave like there's a lot of people I
guess I just feels like you know growing
up and loving PC games and stuff that
like there's just more acceptability or
like everyone's found each other like
the Internet we used to be like
disparate like either you're in your
small community like I grew up in the
south of Ireland and like you're trying
to find people who like the things yeah
yeah the internet came along and was
like oh we're all there yeah I can find
each other this is that what's happened
with the indie as well as it like it's
it's broken down what we're sort of you
know the internet helps a lot I think we
find a lot of people that are like I
really like what's happening here I'd
like to play it for the first time and
because of the community that happens in
the chat on the geek and sundry twitch
channel they find each other they'll do
these online games and all of a sudden
they're off and running to the races and
you found these like-minded people that
get to kind of nerd out and completely
explore something they've never tried
before you're like let's go kill the
chromatic dragon let's talk all that
stone giant whatever like yeah we're
gonna do that anywhere else and if they
don't have that immediate immediately
available to them like where they are
the Internet's fantastic for that it's
like the happiest the internet has ever
been it's like the happiest slice of the
Internet and yet we have
critter games to have popped up where
there will literally be a different
player on a different continent like
each person is in a different country
and that's like that's the beauty of
accent heaven - yeah yeah and and the
charity work that let alone what what
the community has given but then they
are often doing their own charity games
on their own Twitter these little
personal groups and so it's just it's
promoting all this positivity in the
world and helping out people that need
it and it's it's just I'm perpetually
blown away and humbled by the fact that
we're even part of this whole thing and
I think a lot of has to do with one the
cultural zeitgeist as far as geek
culture is concerned a lot of people
that grew up playing video games and and
and playing tabletop games they are
inheriting the entertainment industry
it's all the sellers the script writers
the directors the performers these are
the people that grew up you know the
basement geeks the indoor kids like us
and so now they're the ones who are
creating the media and putting it out
there since what they've always wanted
to see also we're looking at a
generation now that was raised on the
internet people that they're only really
gaming experience so they've had a lot
of time with has been via the Internet
Xbox Live you know switcher which is a
great experience in its own right but
there is a deep down cultural need to be
with people that you don't have a excuse
to do often an and so in recent years I
feel like there's been this emerging
need for you know board games and
tabletop games because people are
getting to really really can get our
friends together and not have to land
party we can just play at a table in
this each of those faces and it's as fun
it's really cool it's such a strange
revert role reversal I guess yeah um I
mean I was talking to Laura about it
earlier about how there's something
about the like the RPG group of gamers
we're like I think about you know
playing World of Warcraft and I like
barely had anyone ever give me any like
stick or any like grief on that I don't
want it like a four-fight play that game
you weren't on the kill Rob PvP side
stick stick to the RPG servers yeah but
I mean like have you ever thought about
using critical role to like get some of
these people to meet each other have
they had meet and greets themselves have
you thought about doing an event like
its I was like kind of funny live a
couple of weeks Mac I like watching
ongoing like oh
my god right like all these people are
meeting them to each other and like this
never would have happened unless that
event came came along we're definitely
considering it other things that are
being planned yep there are things that
are in the work most cons that we go to
we try and do an off-site meetup just
for the people who aren't able to get
badges we try and find like a game store
that's willing to host us I mean there's
been a few there's been a few critical
role couples that have responded Wow
tell me any tattoos how do you mean
that's a loaded question graphically
yeah yeah it's it's wild are further the
first critical role baby that is
conceived we have to have like some kind
of over that child do you like a
character sheet and name the child team
be so great
have you guys ever thought about
changing the game well do you think
you'll ever like change characters do
you think eventually I mean what even
happens like what has to happen for that
too huh well that's a very real thing
right okay you need to have a fight
though and you guys are too good to be
true well conversely every story has an
end and they're they're climbing right
now into kind of the upper echelon of
the world's issues when you start a game
in low levels you're talking about like
small local problems or and it's and
goblins then you get to the area in the
game where you like where you're you're
saving small townships or you know big
big merchants corrupt merchants yeah you
work up to like saving a kingdom and you
work up to saving a country they're just
now cresting past the saving a country
and like the world territory so when
they finish that scale we're gonna end
the campaign might try a different RPG
system for a short time as a palate
cleanser and then come back with
everyone back with new characters at
level one and start a whole new story
from there that's probably what we're
gonna do fun tree saver we're a pretty
big deal Danny
like super important in this fantasy
world that we all make up in our minds
these guys are pretty legit ever bored
like emailing you saying like why did
you do that why did you make it every
time and the hundreds of tweets you
forgot this you didn't do that I forgot
to add I asked you this so no math math
is never gonna be good for us but that
also means people are engaged like you
go to the reddit critical role and
stopping and yeah they're people having
constructive criticism about decisions
that were made in the game but that's
part of the fun of it too
you know we're we're in the moment we
don't no player is gonna make the most
optimal decision when you're on the spot
and thinking in that space you know but
it's cool to see people engaging that
question wanting to kind of be like well
if I was there I would have done this
and like what would that have happened
and is it just creates this whole kind
of discussion which is really fun yeah
I'm going to say it's kind of nice when
you mess up like when you make when you
make the wrong decision it's almost more
entertaining than every time but yeah
it's that same gene that makes you yell
at fian greyjoy right everybody like why
do something stupid
it's that yeah so it's fine it just
means it's part of the energy on I know
but but kind of what you were saying
before about regret like that you know
to try and fail is better than to not do
it cuz you always had that where I think
the same goes for the game there are
many times in the game where you can
make a safe choice whereas AG as a
character you can be like this will
probably be the most survivable if I've
just back away right but like these are
stories of heroes and legend I always
try running on a show like tonight it's
fun to make those rash choices and do
ridiculous things that might fail
fantastically because damn you have a
story to tell at the end of the day even
if you turned into red paste because of
it yeah I guess that's no it's all of
that is like hanging out with your
friends but then having this like
adventure at the same time sake best of
both worlds
yeah well we're here at e3 yeah have you
folks had a chance to play editing
Travis I just ran to Farpoint right
before we came over gonna be our headset
for the first the first time Oh
because I had the little cardboard box
right like comic-con but I'll come to
the future to read it's like soft and
caressing on your head you can't see
outside of it I shot a bunch of aliens I
jumped off a cliff on purpose okay it
was one of the like the vibes or what
was it it was the place issue okay
should we call the Morpheus and now it's
just the place Iraq VR yeah yeah I'm
they was there like a plastic or
something you can look down the radical
and I was a little excited
I got I started laughing out loud I may
have hit them you know there's like a
person behind you that stands there
right in case you start wandering off
yeah I hit him once yeah if you want to
watch people be weird on virtual reality
there is a VR porn section on the oh
yeah I'm not gonna go there after where
is it
someone from behind was just like it was
great thanks bro the future is now
immersive you get a chance to play
knitting
I played holy [ __ ] the train just left
and we're not on it yet yeah the best
Arg we've experienced are candy are
looks incredible I want to try that put
on the cow I want to go right the giant
chocobo that's here right yes there's a
real thing that I want to do like a
little theme park in there at the moment
sadly yeah every morning there's like a
line of about 200 people to get in and
that's like exhibitor badges so you can
win the public a minutes oh man that's
saying I rendered on Christ when I want
to drink in Wayne man or two before I
leave yeah drinks what yeah you can have
a Harvey Dent oh really
yeah you have to laughter yeah yeah you
have no choice yeah the show is closed
in four hours is there anything you're
gonna try and rush out and get to any
games you're in that you want to sort of
see or I'm rushing over to the master
Otto booth in the Sony area we're doing
couple interviews there after this so
Macerata is a really cool indie RPG that
was made by a Singapore company and it
looks amazing so that's coming up as a
bunch of games in the floor that I can't
talk about
like James Bible you know it's my
favorite thing about talking to you
folks it's being like tell me about all
the games you were in last year yeah
anything yeah but you are still trending
along on geek and sundry it's getting
bigger yeah it's been crazy and cut
across the growing for people who want
to check it out where can they go when
you guys live you can find it on on
Twitch every Thursday night at 7:00 p.m.
Pacific time at wwe.com slash geek and
sundry so you go ahead and check that
out if it's a different time zone you
can go ahead and watch it and oh my god
you did not do that I had to live with
this guys do you do that when you play
over what I've done it yeah I've messed
with my team the number of times that's
worked yeah do they go oh you don't
sound like him at all bro
well they confuse me like there's
nothing McCree on their side because it
induces so much fear I need to hide
behind something idiot yeah remember
also messing like beats 9:45 it's like
11:59 exactly it's so much fun to mess
as well thank you so much going on was a
pleasure to talk yeah we'll be back in
just a hot second here on the GameSpot
co-op stage with more critical role
you